the seeds are sown but the UK's tomato
Harvest is yet to bear fruit and it's
likely to be a disappointing one this
year Rising Heating and fertilizer costs
are forcing Growers to cut production at
a time when Imports are drying up
because of poor weather at Lee Valley
one of Britain's biggest fruit and veg
nurseries Growers would usually have a
crop of tomatoes ready by now but
they've had to delay the season by two
months whether in Spain and in North
Africa there's food shortages and that's
only going to continue because we've
delayed planting so where we'd have
British produce on our shelves now
cucumbers peppers and tomatoes would
have followed it's been delayed by
another three four weeks so this is just
the start of it in the UK we produce
about half of the food we consume but
the balance is likely to tip away from
UK Growers as rising food Fuel and
fertilizer costs forced them to delay or
stop production altogether and if
Imports can't fill the Gap then empty
Supermarket shelves could become a
common occurrence go back to having
vegetables that are in season and you
know not worry about it yeah and grow in
our own country we find it you know it's
going short and the price has gone
so expensive
Morrisons and Asda have already started
rationing some fresh produce limiting
purchases of tomatoes cucumbers and
lettuce to two or three per customer
but experts say consumers may have to
put up with higher prices unfortunately
we have seen inflation in food prices
we're anticipating that we'll fall as we
go through this year but I think we're
still seeing very unusually high prices
in supermarkets at the moment
food production in the UK is slumping as
the country's Reliance on Imports
increases
British Growers say they want to help
but right now they can't afford to feed
the nation
gurpreet no one Sky News